ils étaient montés ensemble sur les
planches pour réciter des poèmes
d'Apollinaire 2 ans après les revoilà
Jean-Louis Trintignan et sa fille Marie
joue au théâtreberto à Paris une pièce
qui parle de l'amour paternel à croire
que le texte de comédie sur unquetgar a
été écrit pour eux Dominique penset
marque
dou on était sur un quai de gare on
attendait un train et puis tout d'un
coup tu t'es levé et tu es allé
rejoindre un étranger mais au moment de
dispar tu t'es retourné tu m'as dit ne
t'en fais pas papa je reviens voilà moi
c'est com sur un c'est l'histoire d'un
homme vieillissant qui essaie de trouver
à sa fille un homme idéal un homme qui
serait capable d'aimer cette fille tant
chérie autant que lui il aime comédie
sur ungard est donc le récit d'un amour
fou entre un père et sa fille quand on
connaî la tendresse que Jean-Louis
trintigant porte à sa fille Marie on se
dit que ces deuxl ne pouvaient rêver
mieux pour des retrouvailles théâtrales
père c'est pas nous hein on n'est pas
comme ça vraiment dans la vie mais ça
nous va très bien il y a toujours un
petit décalage par rapport à nos
rapports mais ce qu'on les rapports
qu'on a dans la vie nous servent
énormément c'est certain mais qu'est-ce
qui te prend ma chérie je t'ai jamais vu
comme ça en
révolte je fais une
crise une crise de quoi d'adolescent
un peu tardif certes mais bon chacun son
rythme c'est presque une pièce qu'on
pourrait jouer sur une place n'importe
où et qui qui serait compréhensive pour
des gens qui n'ont aucune culture
théâtrale on a pas besoin de tout ça
pour pour être pris par la pièce moi ce
que je veux c'est ton bonheur mais il y
a pas 10 minutes ton bonheur c'était
qu'on rentre à la maison et qu'on
reprenne notre vie d'avant ah non il
faut arrêter avec notre vie d'avant elle
me surprendent beaucoup par son sérieux
merci et puis elle me surprend aussi
quand même elle est très étonnante comme
comédienne elle est vraiment très
étonnante tout à l'heure quand tu es
parti je me suis rendu compte que je
pourrais jamais vivre sans toi je me
demande si je suis pas un vieux con il
me surprend et par
ça par sa peur de que qu'on a tous mais
c'est joli quand ça continue et par par
son jeu un père et une fille qui joue à
se séduire sur un ton décalé dans une
infinie douceur on ne s'étonnera pas
d'AP
coméie sur un se donne à guichet
ferm